for the first girl you know she's
described as very like Alpha dominant
very sexy which is really cool but I
think like you know maybe our
personalities wouldn't Vibe because she
is a very dominant person and I don't
think I'm looking for someone like that
I think like for the second person she
is like really cool and very fascinating
because she's like working on herself
you know she's trying to go outside of
her comfort zone and I really appreciate
that in person right now I'm looking for
someone who's just more fun and bubbly
so I'm gonna choose the third girl
oh what's up nice to meet you I'm Ray
hey
how's your little date it was uh you
guys get married do we get married did
you get married already yo I love you yo
you guys look mad cute and your child's
either gonna be named Jay or or Tay or k